you can either stand up
and take that small step forward
you don't have to know where you're
going you don't have to have the perfect
plan you don't
have to know what tomorrow holds but you
can either
get up and take that small step or
you're going to sit at that kitchen
counter
for the rest of your life and now
years later and one of my favorite lines
in the book
i'm thankful that i
pushed through those hard times and i
realized
and i truly believe in now that the
smallest of steps eventually completes
the grandest of journeys
and that is one of the parts of my
mission that i am trying to
get out there and tell people and
educate people about
and this is by no means ending it i
already i'm
still excited and looking forward to
keep going but with that said
i appreciate you having me in in this
time
and helping me with your platform
with that mission of helping people
through that struggle
and telling people that
one small step at a time you work hard
try to stay positive try to be a good
person do the right thing
and you know it'll not only bring you
out of that but take you to great places
yeah i don't have anything to add to
that
i mean that's uh that's
such a poignant thing
to perspective to have and and it's
you know i often talk about the fact
that
the first step is the hardest one in
many situations like the first step
is the hardest one and
and what i like about what you bring to
that statement is like it doesn't matter
how big that step is
or more important how small that step is
you gotta do something you gotta you you
gotta move
in the right direction um
yeah and you detail that just there's a
whole chapter in here
um where you where you go through that
and
people gotta people gotta pick this up
to really reinforce those
ideas so that we can push through it
you know here's here's one of the things
you say kind of bringing this home at
some point everyone will face a rock
bottom moment
when the past looms too large to
overcome and a hopeful future seems too
far out to imagine i mean just think
about that right there
there's times that you're gonna face
where the past is too much
and and the future seems too far away
too far out there
you go on it's difficult to prepare
yourself for that moment because it's
impossible to know what will trigger it
it may be a major setback that knocks
you to the ground or could be something
so
seemingly minor and innocuous like
trying to eat a bowl of cereal which is
what you went through
the point is you can't really do much
ahead of time to prevent that moment
from happening you might not even be
able to brace yourself for the impact
all you can do is commit yourself to
surviving for another day and
recognizing
that you can't change what is behind you
only what lies ahead
you may even wonder if it's possible to
move on and it might not be without
professional guidance to help you
process everything that your past
represents
it's not a process that can be rushed
you have to be honest with yourself
as to whether or not it's time to let go
of the past
past maybe the answer is not yet and
that's okay but at some point you have
to be willing to say
from this day forward i am choosing to
live
too often we fall into the trap of
thinking we need to have everything
figured out before we act
you don't have to have a roadmap before
you set out
you don't even have to know what
direction you're traveling you just have
to be willing
to move and leave the past behind
so
this is just you know powerful stuff and
you you
you go through and you talk about you
know you went jumping with jay redman
who's been on the podcast and you know a
seal that was wounded
very badly you did a bunch of mud runs
with the marine corps like you're doing
stuff you're pushing and and this kind
of you know this is what you say about
that about those things every
obstacle i took on had a whole new
significance and every time i conquered
one
i took on new significance too i gained
significance as someone who fought to
live and was succeeding i gained
significance
as a combat survivor who was doing more
than just surviving
i gained significance as someone who
attacked physical and occupational
therapy
with every fiber of my being and was now
proving
what my restored body could do i gained
significance as someone who refused to
let fear make his choices for him
i gained significance as someone who
reclaimed his life
unapologetically and even if that
significance was only apparent to me
and no one else had changed who i was in
my own eyes
and in my own mind my injuries will not
define my life
i will and the greatest power i have
that any of us has is the power to make
that
choice
so once again it is about taking control
over what choices you make deciding to
move forward
yeah and again it's one thing when
somebody says that stuff
that you know their their big challenge
was who knows what what big challenge
they had but to hear it coming from you
who's literally been dead
and and and come back and suffered
through
the the the recovery process you know
it's just
if you can say that we can all say that
and uh just to add on to that and thanks
for pointing that out but
that's exactly why
along with having to realize how i
wanted to approach and write it
that's why this book was written now
nine years later because i didn't want
to write a book
not only that only military service
members veterans or people that have
been to combat could understand
i wanted a book that
that
i lived i i lived
learned and and
proved and completed the lessons that i
am teaching and the worst is
when you get whether a book or
some motivator out there telling you
you know a whole spreadsheet of things
you need to do
and they haven't done it themselves and
so the last thing
i i wouldn't have wrote it if i wouldn't
have have done these things but
i'm not going to tell people you know
after you get knocked down you can go to
college
earn your degree without doing that i'm
not going to tell people
oh you work hard you know one foot in
front of the other
and eventually one day you can run a
marathon without crossing the finish
line of that marathon
without jumping out of the plane
backpacking across
europe so uh thank you
for recognizing that and i just wanted
to add that
you know people ask me like oh you could
have wrote a book
right after this happened i mean your
story was there
after the medal you know pretty much
would have been the same book
in a way yes but not really because
i uh
i wanted to
i wanted to have substance behind the
things the lessons the
the challenges and victories that i talk
about in this book